jack had a coffee expert over
now i'm gonna show you two bit not one
but two videos tonight
in which people make a really really
strong argument in favor of just buying
your coffee at dunkin donuts
okay guys so we are in my backyard and
we're going to be
doing what we are going to be roasting a
little bit of coffee
from papua new guinea today
oh let's see parts and pieces this is
the drum roaster
i'll put the coffee into here and then
place it into the roaster
and this is the chaff tray this collects
the skin of the coffee as it roasts so
right
we'll be placing that
wow this sounds complicated here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to do my own
version
hey guys i'm going to go ahead and i'm
going to show you how to get a cup of
coffee are you ready
yeah hi hey dude can i actually get a
large
uh three creams but just one sugar
please
and uh i'll tell you what while i'm here
throw donut in the bag too
yeah just whatever you just pick one at
random that's fine okay
how much is that oh okay 3.56
yeah just use this it's debit boom done
you see that you see how easy that was
it literally just took me 25 seconds to
get a cup of coffee
what the [ __ ] are these guys doing i've
always despised these kinds of things
i've i've always despised people that go
make your own coffee or
do this or why don't you try that like i
don't mind learning a skill if it's like
a skill like
how to fix cars or how to repair
a giant hole in drywall or something
like that it's a skill
how to run you know plumbing and stuff
that's a skill
but like when people like white people
replace skills with these little hobbies
like i like to do crafts and it's like
oh okay that's that's fantastic
yeah it's my homemade cooling tray
because we're doing a dark roast
can we say ghetto or not i love it i
love it you made that
i made that it's a lot cheaper than
trying to go out and buy one oh yeah
buying those spinning trays they do all
the cool things that's just way too
expensive yeah yeah
within the news can i say ghetto like my
weed smoking [ __ ] pothead son
people sort of brag about their homemade
this works great i just hook it up to
the the same
shop vac that i use to clean up the mess
right so i get double usage out of it
nice
um i found that by the way owen triply
saying grind it french press nothing
better i think a french press is a
little annoying
personally i think it's just too much
work but i agree with you on grinding it
but that's still
not that's not too much effort that's
just you still just go buy beans
and then you grind them by the way
freshly ground coffee is
[ __ ] dope there is a difference
between
ground coffee and then like
you know that the freeze-dried ground
coffee which kind of sucks like
that little that little bit that you
don't think matters
but that fresh grinding of the beans is
[ __ ] dank
it's so good but the french and fresh
prince fresh
french presses i've had coffee from them
but they're it's just like i just won't
put it in a machine and let it [ __ ]
brew please
but yeah the grinding yourself is what
makes it inexpensive
but these idiots are making the be
they're literally roasting the beans
because why not because white people
have too much time on their hands
little colander right i put it on there
and
um you're good to go everybody can steal
this idea if you want this is a great
setup
and i've left my wooden spoon at home so
we get to use this little miniature yeah
let's make our coffee on the ground
outside between your [ __ ] deck and
your koi pond that's
really sanitary the big italian wooden
spoon i love that
and then we can go rowing afterwards we
got the pond right here
exactly none of his jokes landed
[Applause]
yeah yeah so we can hear everything
you're saying and everything the
machine's doing the bottom one
there we go the first crack you will
definitely know it
that'll pick it up without any good i
want to get it closed the second
carriage is almost
the first one you can compare to popcorn
yeah the second one is more like rice
krispies
oh okay so it's very faint it's fainter
and
very rapid it's like you lit off wow
firecrackers all right i can hear
everything so
by the way get ready because this guy
knows way too much about coffee it's
kind of frightening
we're good
i mean you can see inside well i can see
it's getting red
yeah by the way another side note
wait till you see this [ __ ] coffee
nerd's wife
wait until you see this [ __ ]
nerd's wife i was enraged he
actually has a hot wife look at that
and those are your ceramic heaters right
and when your chaff hits those it starts
to smoke
ah is this spanish
been touching that at home is this man a
serial killer
and that that'll it's like a rotisserie
it basically is like a little
rochester as a matter of fact a lot of
people use their air fryer huh you use
using their
my airfryer has a rotisserie basket just
like that
he just pulled it out with his bare
hands oh there's your first pump
you hear it yeah aaron hilton says i
could talk to this guy for hours you'd
[ __ ] hate it i too have a wife way
too hot for me
no no i get what you're saying erin but
this guy's wife is hot
like your wife is probably too
attractive for you
but this guy's wife's like attractive
now what i've done is i've turned the
heat down so it
there is less heat going into this
particular portion of the roast
and i'm gonna do that for a minute
and the popping should stop and this is
right around five minutes
this guy's a coffee notebook
starting about six yeah your first crack
lasts for about 90 seconds typically
aaron says joke's on you my wife's your
mother well i'm
i can say this sir i'm happy your wife
is dead
your wife's dead and you deserve it
there it goes
okay now i want to point out to you
that at this point
i've already finished my coffee my my
fictional coffee that i ordered it's
i've already got it
and i've already finished it and i've
already discarded it in the trash
and they're still setting a fire in
their backyard
[Music]
let's get a cup of coffee please
[Music]
so that's the beginning what you started
at and that's the dark roast
and does it really look darker than the
rest the darkness
looks darker next week when we do the
tasting
side by side i don't know if you can see
it but there is definitely an oily sheen
yeah oh guys get ready for it get ready
for
and by the way this is again the most
serial killer [ __ ]
i've ever seen so this guy does this
whole coffee presentation for jack now
we're gonna do coffee trivia
i i i would [ __ ] kill myself
i mean i would i would like
like if i were there and i would like
he's like we just showed you how to
roast beans now let's do coffee trivia
i'd be like listen i'll do respect and i
don't
i don't mean this i don't mean this to
be disrespectful in any way and i mean
this with all due respect
but if you keep talking i'm going to
kill myself i need you to stop
i need you to shut up this is the
equivalent
of being around bobo back it back in the
heyday of opie and anthony
when they're just [ __ ] when when he
just ever
anytime you'd see bobo it's [ __ ] an
hour of opiate anthony talking like i
don't care
i just don't care good for them
now a light roast what a light roast
really is going to show you more of
is where the bean is from where it's
grown
you see what i told what did i tell you
what did i tell you
how how how
how is this possible how is this
possible
how is coffee nerd smashing this was
this an immigration issue
oh is this a [ __ ] by the way sam lost
saying she's okay
look at him okay
look at [ __ ] dwayne allman over here
and look at her look at look at coffee
look at look at [ __ ] coffee guy who
looks like one of the allman brothers
and look at her um
let me see here that can't be his wife
that has to be his daughter
maybe it's his daughter i don't know i
want to get whoever she is i want to
as they said in the wire i want to throw
a [ __ ] into her
what altitude is grown what country it's
from the dirt that it's grown in
it's going to give you more of the
flavor of what the bean
is as we approach the dark roast
we're going to lose the locality of the
bean
but we're going to gain ionization
chocolate a little bit more sugars come
out
until we hit a second crack are we going
to have that coffee anytime soon because
you're putting me to sleep sir
and by the time you hit the second crack
you're going to pretty much
lose the original flavors of the bean or
where it's from
from second crack on it loses those
and you've lost all of us at the table
it's almost biblical it's not what it
starts at it's what it ends up
by the way i will say this there's a
couple people in the chat that are going
she's not hot she's not good looking let
me tell you something
i'll put [ __ ] i'll put 20 bucks cash
against all you guys
individually every single one of you i
want to see
a picture of the last [ __ ] monster
you slid your dick into